president joe blyton speaking
this evening in kabul as you all know
terrorists
attacked
that we've been talking about and
worried about
that the intelligence community
has assessed has undertaken
an attack by a group known as isis k
took the lives of american service
members
standing guard at the airport and
wounded several others seriously
he had also wounded a number of
civilians and civilians were killed as
well
i've been engaged all day
in constant contact
with the military commanders here in
washington the pentagon
as well as in afghanistan and
doha
and uh
my commanders here in washington in the
field
have been on this with
great detail and you've had a chance to
speak to some
so far
the situation on the ground is still
evolving
and i'm constantly being updated
these american service members who gave
their lives
it's an overused word but it's totally
appropriate here we're heroes
heroes
who've been engaged in a dangerous
selfless mission
to save the lives of others
they're a part of an airlift an
evacuation effort unlike any scene in
history
with more than 100 000
american citizens
american partners
afghans who helped us
and others taken to safety
in the last 11 days
just the last 12 hours or so another 7
000 have gotten out
they're a part of the bravest most
capable the most selfless military on
the face of the earth
and they're part of simply what i call
the backbone of america
they're the spine of america
the best the country has to offer
jill and i
our hearts ache
like i'm sure all of you do as well
for all those afghan families who lost
loved ones including small children
or been wounded in this vicious attack
and we're outraged as well as
heartbroken
being the father of a
army major served for a year in iraq and
before that
was in kosovo
as a u.s attorney for
better part of six months in the middle
of a war
when he came home after a year
iraq
was diagnosed like many many coming home
with an aggressive and lethal cancer of
the brain
but we lost
we have some sense like many of you do
what the families of these brave heroes
are feeling today
you get this feeling like you're being
sucked into a black hole
in the middle of your chest
there's no way out
my heart aches for you
but i know this
we have a continuing obligation
a sacred obligation to all of you
the families of those heroes
that obligation is not temporary it
lasts forever
the lies we lost today were lives
given in the service of liberty
the service of security
the service of others
in the service of america
like their fellow brothers and sisters
in arms who've died defending our vision
and our values
and the struggle against terrorism
of the fall on this day
they're part of a great noble company of
american heroes
for those who carried out this attack
as well as anyone who wishes america
harm know this
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down
and make you pay
i will defend our interest in our people
with every measure at my command
over the past few weeks
i know you're many of you are probably
tired of hearing me say it
we've been made aware
by our intelligence community
that the isis k
an arch enemy
the taliban
people who were freed when both those
prisons
were opened
has been planning a complex set of
attacks on the united states personnel
and others
this is why from the outset
i've repeatedly said
this mission was extraordinarily
dangerous
and on why i've been so determined to
limit the duration of this mission
as general mckenzie said this is why our
mission
was designed this is the way it was
designed to operate
operating under severe stress and attack
we've known that from the beginning
as i've been in constant contact with
our senior military leaders and i mean
constant
round the clock
and our commanders on the ground
throughout the day they made it clear
that we can and we must complete this
mission and we will
and that's what i've ordered them to do
we will not be deterred by terrorists
we will not let them stop our mission we
will continue the evacuation
i've also ordered my commanders to
develop operational plans to strike isis
k assets leadership and facilities
we will respond with force and precision
at our time at the place we choose in a
moment of our choosing
here's what you need to know
these isis terrorists will not win
we will rescue the americans that are
there
we will get our afghan allies
and our mission will go on
america will not be intimidated
and i have the utmost confidence in our
brave service members who continue to
execute this mission with courage and
honor to save lives and get americans
our partners our afghan allies out of
afghanistan
every day when i talk to our commanders
i ask them what they need what more do
they need if anything to get the job
done
as they will tell you i granted every
request
i reiterated them today on three
occasions
that they should take the maximum steps
necessary to protect our forces on the
ground on kabul and i also want to thank
the secretary of defense and the
military leadership of the pentagon and
all the commanders in the field
there has been complete unanimity
from every commander on the objectives
of this mission
and the best way to achieve those
objectives
those who've served through the ages
have drawn inspiration from the book of
isaiah
when the lord says whom shall i send
who shall go for us
the american military has been answering
for a long time here i am lord send me
here i am send me
each one of these women and men of our
armed forces are the heirs of that
tradition of sacrifice of volunteering
to go in harm's way to risk everything
not for glory not for profit but to
defend what we love and the people we
love
i ask that you join me now
in a moment of silence
for all those
in uniform
and out
beautiful military and civilian
who've given the last full measure of
devotion
thank you
may god bless you all my god protect us
troops and all those standing watch for
america
we have so much
to do
it's within our capacity to do it
we just have to remain steadfast
steadfast
we will complete our mission
and we will continue
after our troops are withdrawn
to find means by which we can find
any american
who wishes to get out of afghanistan
we will find them and we will get them
out
ladies and gentlemen
he gave me a list here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc
you have said leaving afghanistan is in
the national interest of the united
states after today's attack do you
believe you will authorize additional
forces to respond to that attack inside
afghanistan and are you
are you prepared to add additional
forces to protect those americans who
remain on the ground carrying out the
evacuation operation
i've instructed the military
whatever they need if they need
additional force
i will grant it
but the military
from
the chairman of the joint chiefs the
joint chiefs
the commanders in the field
have all contacted me one way or another
usually by letter
saying
they subscribe to the mission is
designed
to get as many people out as we can
within the time frame
that is allotted
that is the best way they believe to get
as many americans out as possible on
others
and with regard to finding
tracking down
the isis
leaders who ordered
this
we have some reason to believe we
know who they are
not certain
and we will find ways for choosing
without large military operations to get
them
wherever they are
um trevor
reuters
thank you mr president um
there's been some criticism uh even from
people in your party about the
dependence on the taliban to secure the
perimeter of the airport do you feel
like there was
a mistake
made in that regard
no i i don't look um i think general
mckenzie handled this
question very well
the fact is that
we're in a situation
inherited the situation particularly
since as we all know
that the afghan military collapsed 11
days
before
in 11 days
that it is in the interest
of as mckenzie said
in the interest of the taliban
that in fact
isis k does not
metastasize beyond what it is
number one
and number two
it's in their interest that
we are able
to leave on time
on target
as a consequence of that
the major things we've asked them
moving back the perimeter
giving more space between the wall
stopping vehicles from coming through
etc
searching people coming through
it is not what you'd call
a
tightly commanded regimented operation
like the u.s us's the military is
but
they're acting in their interest
their interest
and so
by and large and i've asked this same
question
to military on the ground
whether or not it's a useful exercise no
one trusts them
we're just counting on their
self-interest
to continue
to generate their activities
and it's in their self-interest
that
we leave when we said
and that we get as many
people out as we can
like i said even in the midst of
everything happened today over 7 000
people we've gotten out over 5 000
americans overall
so
it's not a matter of trust it's a matter
of
mutual self-interest
and uh
but
there is no evidence thus far
that i've been given as a consequence by
any of our commanders in the field
that there has been
collusion
between the taliban and isis
and carrying out
what happened today
both in front of the hotel and what is
expected to continue
for uh beyond
today
um
amir
associated press
thank you mr president
you
have spoken um
again powerfully about
uh your own son and the weight of these
decisions
with that in mind and also what you've
said um that the longer we stay the more
likelihood that there would be a major
attack
how do you weigh staying even one more
day considering what's happened
because i think what america says
matters
what we say we're going to do in the
context in which we say we're going to
do it that we do it
unless something exceptional changes
there are
additional
american citizens
there are additional green card holders
there are additional personnel
of our allies
their additional siv
card holders
there are additional afghans that have
helped us
and there are additional
groups of individuals
that have been contacted us from
women's groups to ngos and others
who have
expressly indicated they want to get out
and have
gathered
in certain circumstances
in groups
on buses and other means
that still presents the opportunity
for the next
several days between now and the 31st to
be able to get them out
and
our military
and i believe
to the extent that we can do that
knowing
the threat
knowing that we may very well have
another attack
the military has concluded that's what
we should do
i think they're right
i think they're correct
and after that
we're going to be in a
circumstance where
there are
will be i believe numerous opportunities
to continue to provide access
for additional persons
to get out
of
afghanistan
either
through
means that we provide and or
are provided
through in cooperation with
the taliban they're not good guys
taliban they're not suggesting that at
all
but they have keen interest
as many of you have been reporting
they very much would like to figure out
how to keep the airport open they don't
have the capacity to do it
they very much are trying to figure out
whether or not they can uh
maintain
what is a portion of an economy that has
become
not robust but fundamentally different
than it had been
and so there's a lot of reasons why
they have
reached out not just to us but to others
as to
why it would be continued in their
interest
to get more of the personnel
we want to get out we can locate them
now there's not many left that we can
assess
that are want to come out
there's some americans we've identified
we've contacted the vast majority of
them not all of them
who don't want to leave
because they have their dual nationals
they have extended families
etc
and there's others who uh
are looking for the time
so
that's why we continue i'll take a few
more questions and uh but you sir
i wanted to ask you
you say that what america says matters
what do you say to the afghans who
helped troops um who may not be able to
get out by august 31st
to try to get you out it matters look
i know of no conflict
as a student of history
no conflict
where when a war was ending
one side was able to guarantee that
everyone
they wanted to be extracted from that
country
would get out and think about it folks
i think it's important i know the
american people get this in their gut
there are
i would argue millions
of afghan citizens
who are not taliban
who did not actively cooperate
with us as sivs
who have given a chance
they'd be on board a plane tomorrow
it sounds ridiculous but the vast
majority of people in communities like
that want to come to america given a
choice
so
getting every single person out
is
can't be guaranteed by anybody because
there's a determination all who wants to
get out as well any rate it's a process
i was really pointing to you but you sir
um
thank you mr president there are reports
that
u.s officials provided the taliban with
names of americans and afghan officials
to evacuate were you aware of that did
that happen and then sir
did you personally reject a
recommendation to hold or to recapture
bagram air force base
here's what i've done on the let's ask
answer the last question first
on the tactical questions of how to
conduct
an evacuation or war
i gather up
all the major military personnel
that are in afghanistan the commanders
as well as the pentagon
and i ask for their best military
judgment
what would be
the most efficient way to accomplish the
mission
they concluded the military
that bagram
was not
much value-added that it was much wiser
to focus on
kabul
and so i followed that recommendation
with regard to
there are certain circumstances
where we've gotten information and quite
frankly sometimes some
some of you
saying you know of such and such a group
of people are
trying to get out they're on a bus
they're moving
from
other people
and this is their
location and there have been occasions
when
our military has contacted their
military counterparts
in the taliban and said this for example
this bus is coming through
with x number of people on it
made up of the following group of people
we want you to let that bus or that
group through
so yes there have been occasions like
that
and to the best of my knowledge
in those cases the bulk of that has
occurred they've been let through
but i can't tell you with any certitude
that there's actually been a list of
names i know there may have been but i
know of no circumstance it doesn't mean
it's not didn't exist
that here's the names of 12 people that
are coming and let them through that
could very well have happened i'll take
one more question
wait wait let me take the one question
from the most interesting guy that i
know in the press
that's you
mr president there had not been a u.s
service member killed in combat in
afghanistan since february of 2020.
you set a deadline you pulled troops out
you sent troops back in
and now 12 marines are dead you said the
buck stops with you do you bear any
responsibility
for the way that things have unfolded in
the last two weeks i bear responsibility
for
fundamentally all that's happened
of late but here's the deal
you know i wish you one day say these
things you know as well as i do
that a former president
made a deal with the taliban
that he would get all american forces
out of
afghanistan by may 1.
in return the commitment was made and
that was a year before
in return he was given a commitment
that the taliban
would continue to attack
others but would not attack any american
forces
remember that
i'm being serious
no i i'm asking you a question
because before
no no no wait a minute i'm asking you a
question is that accurate the best
you're not
what
do you
i think
they have an issue
that
people
are like to get hurt
some as we've seen gotten killed
and that it is messy
the reason why whether my friend will
acknowledge it or has reported it
the reason why there were no attacks on
americans as you said from the date
until
i
came into office
was because the commitment was made
by president trump i will be out by may
1st
in the meantime you agree not to attack
any americans that was the deal
that's why no american was attacked
a few days ago you said you stand by
your decision to pull out yes i do
because look at it this way folks and
i'm gonna i have another meaning for
real
but
imagine
where we'd be
if i had indicated
on may the first
i was not going to renegotiate
a
evacuation date
we were going to stay there
i'd have only one alternative
poor thousands of more troops back into
afghanistan
to fight a war
that we had already won relatives by the
reason we went in the first place
i have never been of the view that we
should be
sacrificing american lives
to try to establish
a democratic government
in
afghanistan
a country that has never once in its
entire history
been a united country
and has made up
i don't mean this in a derogatory made
up of different tribes
who have never ever ever gotten along
with one another
and so
as i said before this last comment i'll
make we'll have more chance to talk
about this
unfortunately beyond because we're not
out yet
if
osama bin laden
as well as al-qaeda
had chosen
to launch an attack
when they left saudi arabia out of
yemen
would we have ever gone to
afghanistan
even though the taliban completely
controlled afghanistan at the time
would we have ever gone
i know it's not fair to ask you
questions this is rhetorical but raise
your hand if you think we should have
gone
and given up
thousands of lives
and tens of thousands of wounded
our interest
in going was to prevent al-qaeda from
re-emerging
first to get bin laden
wipe out al-qaeda in afghanistan
prevent that from happening again
as i've said a hundred times
terrorism is metastasized around the
world we have greater threats coming out
of other countries
a heck of a lot closer to the united
states
we don't have military encampments there
we don't keep people there we have over
the rising capability to keep them from
going after us
ladies and gentlemen
it was time to end a 20-year war thank
you so much
[Applause]
right we've been listening to your